so ich hatte nur eine kartoffel jedoch
kein hobby und ich hatte eine kartoffel
so jetzt hab ich mir davon zwei teams
nehmen
ich nehme das eisen schwert und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
spielen wir eine runde sowie games auf
der map zu bringen
und ich habe eine challenge bei euch die
mir einen zuschauer letztens auf
trischen die kommentare geschrieben hat
leute und ich verletzte direkt mit
change lautet die idee dass ich nur ein
item aus der kiste nehmen daraus jeder
kiste noch ein item allerdings wenn ich
ein gegner töten darf ich sage mal hab
ich zwei items von ihm nehmen aber auch
nur zwei so wie jetzt die nächste kiste
das und aus der kiste nämlich dass leute
befinden einen bosch valencia und models
aber das bringt mir nichts wenn ich
keine rüstung ab ich verwende die male
sagt zack zack zack zack ist eine kiste
ob bitte bitte bitte um etwas gutes eine
kartoffel sehr schön
damit kommen wir sehr weit wo warst du
für eine waffe sicher ist es glaube ich
einen trecker sein
nice und privatleute warte warte warte
warte warte alles weg ich hatte nur eine
kartoffel so ich hätte man die kartoffel
hat doch kein hobby und ich hatte eine
kartoffel so jetzt hab ich mir davon
zwei teams nehmen
ich nehme das eisen schwert und den
eisenbahnern ja und den rest der welt
weg sagt zack zack zack zack
und das muss weg sehr schön dass ich
eine kartoffel behalten nein konsequent
die eine kartoffel weggeschmissen
ich will dich nicht kartoffel so ich
habe nur meine eine einzige kartoffel
und keine rüstung leider aber was macht
der vorgeschichte nolte und ich habe
wieder viel zu viele kumpel auf gesagt
du musst alles wegwerfen
okay die egal das war aber glaub ich
eine gute entscheidung mit der sache die
ich gemacht habe ist ihr was ich meine
damit dass ich hier nur zack zack zack
zack zack zack vielleicht ein bisschen
so so so so so weg ich will nämlich auf
jeden fall mal die goldschätze und den
kompass ich mir die gold shares und den
kompass den bogen weit weg
ok gold shares und kompass gut jetzt hab
ich noch nicht zuviel sprinten weil
sonst kann ich nicht regenerieren
ich hab momentan kein funke muss ich mir
erst erkämpfen oder aus der kiste holen
ist was drin vielleicht ja sehr nah ist
aber hier porsche luxury porsche dann
vielleicht eine andere kiste abklappern
größte gegner loben oder wie hey wo ist
der typ im berg drin ist dann ist eine
höhle da oben bis ich da oben bin aber
dann habe ich endlich los angeles war
dann hab ich mal den hintern auf die 3
laut erwische ich mich nicht erwischt
mich nicht okay aber ich muss wieder
alles wegwerfen
junge junge im unitymedia
die muss ich wahrscheinlich liegen
lassen das tut weh das tut weh so das
war meine items und jetzt nämlich von
diesen zwei hier also ich sag mal zwei
von einer sorte ich nehme den helm und
das guckt schicken
das nehme ich mit vier stück waren als
sehr geil geil ich nehme den chain helm
damit ich später keine probleme mit der
s regel bekomme und die leggins nein ich
nun die länge ziehen wir uns natürlich
über die denkmalschutz
wo hast du denn so jens okay ich zieh
mal an und dann wirklich alles andere
wieder weg genau da und dort warte ich
meine alten stuff so das muss dadurch
wegwerfen so jungs sehr neues jungs und
mädels und mädels natürlich auch die
beschweren sich dann die nicht mit
einbeziehen ansagen so gut läuft so weit
darf nicht daran denken ist dabei schon
vielleicht wird wer so eine kiste da ein
bisschen davon an der hier war ich noch
nicht sagen
und da ist tatsächlich was die kubot
sicher mit sehr gut läuft eigentlich
richtig gut die challenge damit das wird
in ein mit dem eisenstädter geklopft
haben das kam uns sehr zugute würde ich
sagen
jetzt aber noch vier mann und ich werde
versuchen dass ich die runde gewinne ich
spielen darf man schon ein bisschen
snooki und defensiv eine hübsche oder
ist so potthoff aktiver schwert motto
bitte katharina na ja den habe ich gut
erwischt nein bitte nicht ich bin ganz
klein und hilflos
nein nein nein nein robert ist habe ich
die leitung von dem mitgenommen erzählt
mir weg damit nicht alles weg alles weg
alles weg ich nehme auf jeden fall dass
das feuerzeug zack und die angel
vielleicht noch der rest muss weg waren
beim bahnfahren bamm bamm bamm auch im
deathmatch wird die challenger
konsequent durchgehalten
sehr schön vorbildlich und 6,5 jahr noch
von dem die müssen alle weg bis auf die
zwei die schon hatte
nein okay was macht die helfer zwei cops
vor so jetzt glaube ich den weg damit
vornehmlich getötet aber egal ob ich
nicht sogar bislang leider nur was
alt hatte er mich schnell down krass man
jedoch soll das ging mir richtig schnell
aber es war eine sehr gute challenge
wenn ich dich auch noch konsequent
durchgezogen
nur wie schnell hat er mich bitte
gekillt alter das waren die fünf herzen
in einer sekunde
okay aber er muss cool angestellt wenn
ich irgendwann mal so was in dieser
sorte dieser art einverstanden kommentar
schreiben will mit über nicht die gut
finde
da nehme ich auch gerne meinem video
dran bis dahin heute montag der
vierzehnte war ein relativ langer tag
mein erster tag praktikum das kann ich
noch erzählen
ich war von 10 bis 10 bis 18.30 daten um
20 uhr zu hause dann bin ich erstmal
eingepennt zu hause und dann jetzt macht
gewonnen feuers aufgenommen
ich schneide das laz hoch für morgen
gesetzt produzenten bis dahin hat rein
macht gut und ciao